workers on the Gulf Coast are cleaning
up this morning after hurricane Nate
made landfall in Louisiana and
Mississippi 85 mile-per-hour winds along
with rain and dangerous storm surge
pounded the region no deaths were
reported in the US as a system move
north
it brought tornadoes and strong winds to
the Carolinas this morning the storm is
moving northeast dumping rain from
Virginia to Maine it's raining here in
New York Manuel Bojorquez is in Hudson
North Carolina where a tornado damaged
homes man well good morning good morning
the tornado touched down here yesterday
evening and not only did it bring down
these massive trees but as you can see
here it also knocked down power lines
and take a look at this this was a
two-car garage that was simply
demolished by the tornado and on top of
that it also partly ripped off the roof
of the home behind me emergency
officials say at least 30 homes in this
county have some sort of damage he's
naked on the ground I got video dash cam
video appears to show the moment a
tornado touched down in Caldwell County
North Carolina
family throughout the Carolinas Sunday
tornadoes and funnel clouds were
reported as remnants of Hurricane eight
moved through the category one storm
slammed the Mississippi coast Sunday
morning just hours after it made its
first landfall in Louisiana the strength
of the hurricane-force winds could be
seen in this parking garage in Biloxi as
it filled with water this is inside the
Golden Nugget Casino the entrance to the
Golden Nugget Casino in Biloxi looked
more like a swimming pool
despite Nate's ferocity most of the Gulf
states were spared major damage but
parts of the Carolinas don't seem to be
as lucky like slow rotation and then all
sudden just all come together at one
time an apparent twister ripped through
Burke County North Carolina knocking
this home off its foundation uprooting
trees and snapping power poles at the
Cleveland County Fair people were
ordered to evacuate as an ominous black
cloud hovered above
across the border in South Carolina a
possible tornado flattened mobile homes
in Pickens County this home was
destroyed while a family was still
inside they sought shelter and corner of
the residence and that happens to be the
only part of the house is still standing
crews are now working to restore power
there have been injuries reported in the
Carolinas and a North Carolina
firefighter was killed struck by a car
during storm cleanup such a vicious
hurricane season man well thank you